At first you don't really think about it, Bobby says. He got drafted to play professional baseball for the Cubs, was sent to the minor leagues like most players are. And for the first few years, he says, you don't wonder if you'll make it. You know you'll make it. For one thing, the evidence is everywhere.
起初你真的不会多想，鲍比说。他被选中为芝加哥小熊队打职业棒球，像大多数球员一样被下放到小联盟。他说，头几年，你根本不会怀疑自己是否能成功。你知道自己一定能成功。因为证据到处都是。
You see it all the time. You're in AA or even in A-ball and somebody does get the call. We had a shortstop when I was with the Reds. His name was Travis Dawkins. His nickname's Gookie Dawkins. And Barry Larkin got hurt in the big leagues, and the phone call came into the manager's office. And all of a sudden, this buzz started taking over the clubhouse. And it was about Gookie. Gookie's going to the show. And I remember him cleaning out his locker, getting ready to get on the next flight to Cincinnati.
你一直都在亲眼见证。当你身处2A或者A级联盟时，总有人会接到去大联盟的电话。我还在红人队时，有个游击手叫特拉维斯·道金斯，绰号“古奇”·道金斯。后来大联盟的巴里·拉金受伤了，经理办公室接到了电话。突然间，更衣室里开始骚动起来。大家都在谈论古奇。古奇要去大联盟了。我还记得他清理储物柜，准备搭乘下一班飞往辛辛那提的飞机。
So he's your buddy, and you're watching him clean out his locker to go.
所以他是你的好哥们，你看着他清理储物柜准备离开。
Yeah, and that's happened quite a bit. Quite a bit.
是的，这种情况发生过很多次。很多次。
By his third year, out of the 52 guys Bobby was drafted with, only 15 were still playing ball. In his fourth year, he was traded. By his seventh year, he was sitting on the bench a lot. Then he broke his wrist and had a hard time finding a team who would pick him up.
到第三年时，和鲍比同一批被选中的52个人里，只剩下15个还在打球。第四年，他被交易了。到第七年，他大部分时间都坐在板凳上。后来他手腕骨折，很难找到球队愿意签他。
And I think I was pretty rusty, and I was pretty discouraged. I really thought that the time might be sooner than later that I was out of the game. There were quite a bit of people that said, is this it? Can you go back? And the questions started coming, and more regularly as I continued to play.
我觉得自己生疏了，也感到很沮丧。我真的觉得离开这项运动的日子可能不远了。有不少人问我：“这就结束了吗？还能回去吗？”随着我继续打球，这样的问题出现得越来越频繁。
How would people say it? Were they sheepish about it? Or they just didn't even know to be sheepish about it?
人们是怎么问的？他们是觉得不好意思吗？还是说他们根本不知道要不好意思？
I wish they were sheepish about it, frankly. It's frustrating when people would ask. I was always very uncomfortable when people would ask me those type of questions.
说实话，我倒希望他们能感到不好意思。当人们问起这些问题时，真的很令人沮丧。每次被问到这类问题，我都感到非常不自在。
But then his season improved. He actually wen on a kind of streak. And his whole vision of where he was heading came back to him. And that's what keeps somebody going in this situation. There had always been so much proof, you know. He'd been a high school star, an all-state and a college star, an all-Big Ten, and his brother Hal Morris was playing for the Reds.
但后来他的赛季表现好转了。他甚至打出了一波连胜。他对自己未来去向的憧憬又回来了。这就是支撑一个人在这种境况下坚持下去的动力。毕竟，这里一直有太多的证明了，你知道的。他曾是高中明星，入选过州全明星，还是大学明星，入选过十大联盟，而且他哥哥哈尔·莫里斯当时就在为红人队效力。
It's like what happens in a casino. You win enough at the time to keep you going, to keep you in the game. It feels like the big win is right around the corner.
这就像在赌场一样。你时不时赢一点，让你能支撑下去，留在牌局里。你感觉大奖就在转角处。
What got Bobby to finally quit was that that vision of his future was replaced with a different vision of who he might become. At the beginning of his 10th year, he couldn't get onto an affiliated team. He went to the independent leagues, a step down. And when he showed up for spring training and looked around at the other guys, he thought to himself, he was seeing a lot of guys who'd hung on for too long, and wondered if that's who he was becoming. And during one of their very first practice games, he suddenly found he'd decided.
最终让鲍比决定退出的，是他对自己未来的愿景被另一种关于自己未来的形象所取代。在第10年开始时，他找不到一支附属球队。他去了独立联盟，那是降了一级。当他参加春训，环顾四周的其他球员时，他心想，他看到了太多坚持太久的人，他开始怀疑这是否就是自己即将变成的样子。在他们最初的一场练习赛中，他突然做出了决定。
My last at-bat-- I know I've got three at-bats. I grounded out to second base, and I did know. I knew that was it, certainly. I think the moment the ball was off of my bat, I had a thought that this might be the last one. And I ran by, the throw beat me by a couple of steps, and I kept running as hard as I can through the bag. And I just kind of kept going out to the outfield a little bit. I remember thinking after, as I'm decelerating down the baseline, just thinking, well, if this is my last one, it's kind of apropos, because I gave it everything I had. I ran down to first with everything I had, and it just wasn't enough to get me there in time.
我最后一次打击——我知道我有三次打击机会。我打了个滚地球到二垒，我当时就知道了。我确实知道那是最后一次了。我想球离开球棒的那一刻，我就有种感觉，这可能是最后一次了。我跑垒时，传球比我快了几步，但我还是尽我所能向垒包冲刺。我稍微多跑了一段冲到了外野。我记得当时在跑向垒包减速时，心里想，嗯，如果这是最后一次，那也算恰如其分，因为我已经竭尽全力了。我拼尽全力跑向一垒，但还是没能及时赶到。
For years, he'd been wrestling with this decision, and then that was that. He was past deciding. It was done, which I think is pretty much how these kinds of big decisions always go. He went to the batting cage, he hit for a while, for the last time, and then he told his coaches.
多年来，他一直在纠结这个决定，然后一切就结束了。他不再需要纠结了。事情定了，我想这类重大的决定大抵都是如此。他去了打击练习场，打了最后一会儿，然后告诉了教练。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our radio program, "Should I Stay or Should I Go?" We have three stories of people with big decisions to make, usually, like Bobby, between the practical thing, the thing that everybody expects of them, and some vision of something that they just can't give up.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的广播节目主题是“我该留下还是离开？”我们带来了三个关于人们做出重大决定的小故事，通常像鲍比一样，在现实的选择、大家期望他们做出的选择，与他们无法放弃的梦想之间徘徊。
Act One of our show, "The Karachi Kid," in which a college student has to decide whether to stay in America, where he's been going to school, or go back to Pakistan where his family is, because as everybody knows, you can't wipe on and wipe off your visa status.
我们节目的第一幕，“卡拉奇小子”，讲述了一名大学生必须决定是留在美国继续学业，还是回到巴基斯坦的家人身边，因为众所周知，签证状态是不能随意切换的。
Act Two, "Not Far From the Tree." Two software engineers at Apple Computer get fired and then simply refuse to leave.
第二幕，“离树不远”。苹果公司的两名软件工程师被解雇后，却拒绝离开公司。
Act Three, "Because I'm the Mommy, That's Why." A nine-year-old girl has to decide what to do when her mom runs away, runs away with her and her sister in tow. Stay with us.
第三幕，“因为我是妈妈，所以就这样”。一个九岁的女孩必须决定在母亲带她和妹妹离家出走时该怎么办。请继续收听。
Act One. "The Karachi Kid." Muhammad Kamran is an IT student at Drexel University in Philadelphia. He worked and saved for two years to get the money to come to the States, where there are all sorts of difficulties to get a visa.
第一幕。“卡拉奇小子”。穆罕默德·卡姆兰是费城德雷塞尔大学的IT专业学生。他工作并攒了两年钱才凑够钱来到美国，而获得签证存在各种各样的困难。
He's a good student, an observant Muslim, doesn't drink. When he and his American friends go to bars, he sits there with his Diet Cokes. And after being here for school all these years, he's not so sure he wants to go home to Pakistan when he graduates. But he's the eldest son. He's expected to go home and care for his parents as they get older.
他是个好学生，是一名虔诚的穆斯林，不喝酒。当他和美国朋友去酒吧时，他总是坐在一旁喝健怡可乐。在学校待了这么多年后，他不确定毕业后是否还想回巴基斯坦。但他又是长子。按照期望，他得回家照顾年迈的父母。
It's not that I don't want to take care of them. It's just that I want to do both. And I'm trying to figure out, what am I going to do?
并不是我不愿意照顾他们。只是我希望能兼顾。我正在努力搞清楚，我到底该怎么办？
So in the fall, when he went home for the first time in four years, he knew his family was going to do everything possible to convince him to move back to Pakistan after college-- introduce him to marriageable women, show him how modern Karachi has become. He took a tape recorder with him on the trip. His radio diary begins right before he's about to head home.
所以秋天时，当他四年来第一次回家时，他知道家人会尽一切可能说服他在大学毕业后搬回巴基斯坦——给他介绍适婚女性，展示卡拉奇变得有多么现代化。他带了一台录音机踏上旅程。他的广播日记就在他准备回家前开始记录。
The most prominent emotion that I have right now is like, oh, my God, it's been so, so long. I wonder how everything is, and how everyone is. My cousins and my brother-- my brother was 16 when I left and his voice was just breaking then. And now he's a man. He's taller than me. I'm just so excited to go there and see everything.
我此刻最强烈的感受是，天哪，真的过了太久太久了。我好奇一切怎么样了，每个人怎么样了。我的表兄弟和弟弟——我离开时弟弟才16岁，声音才刚刚变声。而现在他是个男人了，比我还高。我真的太兴奋能回去看看一切了。
I'm also scared. People say it's changed a lot. It's become modern and all that. A lot of multinationals have been investing. Restaurants have opened up and there are a lot of clubs and all that kind of stuff. So I'm just scared to see what's there for me now.
我也很害怕。人们说那里变了很多。变得很现代化什么的。很多跨国公司都在那里投资。开了很多餐厅，还有很多俱乐部之类的东西。所以我很害怕看到那里现在是什么样子的。
When my parents sent me to college and stuff, it was understood that, once you finish college, you will come back. There are no two ways about it. And at the time, I was like, yeah, definitely. But now that I've been here, and I see so many opportunities, I want to stay here and explore what else is here. Because it's the US. The world comes here to study and work. I took so hard to get here. Why am I going back? But then-- why am I going back? Because my family, my parents.
当初父母送我上大学时，大家达成共识，只要大学一毕业，我就得回来。没有别的选择。当时我是想，是的，当然了。但现在我在这里待久了，看到了那么多机会，我想留下来探索还有什么可能。因为这是美国。全世界的人都到这里来学习和工作。我费了这么大劲才来到这里。我为什么要回去？但话又说回来，为什么要回去？因为我的家人，我的父母。
I just reached Karachi. Getting off the baggage claim and getting all my stuff now. The flight was great. I sat next to this guy, a Pakistani businessman who was just coming back from Germany. He was telling me that him and his cousin were debating going to college in the US, but at the last minute his dad stopped him and he did not go. But he has no regrets. He likes being in Pakistan, because of the religion and the culture and whatnot.
我刚到卡拉奇。现在正离开行李提取处拿行李。飞行很棒。我旁边坐着一个巴基斯坦商人，他刚从德国回来。他告诉我，他和表兄弟曾商量去美国读大学，但在最后一刻他父亲阻止了他，他就没去。但他一点也不后悔。他喜欢待在巴基斯坦，因为那里的宗教、文化等等。
So I'm in a rickshaw right now. I just bargained to get from Center City Karachi to my house for $1. For one dollar. You've got people honking. There's no concept of courtesy or braking.
我现在坐在一辆人力车上。我刚砍价花1美元从卡拉奇市中心回到家。就一美元。到处都是按喇叭的人。这里没有礼让或刹车的概念。
I must admit, I used to drive the same way before. But there's no concept of lanes. In a place where the US would have two lanes, we have about one, two, three, four-- six lanes made out of two lanes' equivalent in the US. Oh, [BLEEP], there are cows crossing in the middle of the road. This is no system of driving or anything. That's about it.
我必须承认，我以前也是这样开车的。但这里根本没有车道的概念。在美国两条车道的地方，我们这里硬是挤出了五、六条车道。噢，该死，路上有牛在穿行。这根本没有任何交通系统可言。就是这样。
The first three or four days, I was sick. My stomach was running. I was hot. I felt like an American. My God, I was complaining, I was bitching about it. I was like, what the hell is this? Who wants to live here? It was hot. I made it a point to have a yogurt drink every morning just to cool my body down.
前三四天，我病了。拉肚子。天气很热。我觉得自己像个美国人。天哪，我在抱怨，我在发牢骚。我说，这到底是什么鬼地方？谁想住在这里？太热了。我每天早上都特意喝一杯酸奶来降温。
I was very cut back the fourth day, but the fifth day, I was like, OK, this is where I grew up, so I shouldn't complain. This is where I come from. How can I start thinking that I'm a foreigner, even though I felt like one.
第四天我感到好了一些，但第五天时我想，好吧，这是我长大的地方，我不应该抱怨。这是我的根。即便我感觉像个外国人，我怎么能开始觉得自己是个外人呢？
So I told my dad. He definitely wants me to stay in Pakistan or Dubai and work here. So you think I should stay in Pakistan, Abu?
所以我告诉了爸爸。他确实希望我待在巴基斯坦或迪拜工作。所以你觉得我应该待在巴基斯坦吗，爸爸？
Well, after 9/11, you should consider staying back here.
嗯，911之后，你应该考虑留在这里。
Why after 9/11?
为什么是911之后？
It's all in the press, you see. They're saying that there's discrimination against Muslims.
新闻里都说了，你看。他们说对穆斯林有歧视。
I talked to my dad about this. And he kept switching reasons. He kept saying that, why I should come back to Pakistan, because of-- the first reason he gave was discrimination against Muslims and Arabs. And then he said that I should move home because everything's going to be set up for me. I don't have to worry about a house or a car or food and all that.
我和爸爸谈过这件事。他一直在转换理由。他一直说我应该回巴基斯坦的原因，第一个理由就是对穆斯林和阿拉伯人的歧视。然后他又说我应该回家，因为一切都为我安排好了。我不用担心房子、车子或食物这些。
You don't have to start fresh here. We can provide you everything. And then you just have to work.
你不需要在这里从零开始。我们可以为你提供一切。你只要工作就行了。
And then he said that there would be all these opportunities for me, because all these companies are investing in Pakistan.
然后他说，我将会有很多机会，因为所有这些公司都在巴基斯坦投资。
Companies like Halliburton.
像哈里伯顿那样的公司。
But you know who owns Halliburton.
但你知道谁拥有哈里伯顿吗。
Well, that Dick Cheney.
嗯，那个迪克·切尼。
Oh, so you know he owns it.
噢，所以你知道是他拥有的。
Even Bill Gates came and sent a message to our president.
连比尔·盖茨都来了，还给我们的总统发了口信。
I will do some research on this and see if Microsoft is opening something in Pakistan. Not that it's funny, but the way he put it was so silly. He's just being a dad.
我会做些调查，看看微软是不是在巴基斯坦开了什么项目。虽然这并不好笑，但他说的样子太傻了。他只是个操心的爸爸。
So I'm on my way to pick up my friend Binti, who has been my friend for a long, long time. She now works for a multinational in Karachi.
我现在在去接朋友宾蒂的路上，她是我认识很久很久的朋友了。她现在在卡拉奇的一家跨国公司工作。
So, Kamran, how's Hani? Is she your girlfriend?
那么，卡姆兰，哈尼怎么样了？她是你的女朋友吗？
No, actually, she's one of my school friends.
不，事实上，她是我的校友。
Girls and boys can never be friends. So cut the crap. Is she your girlfriend? Would you want her to be your girlfriend?
女孩和男孩之间根本不可能有友谊。少废话了。她是你的女朋友吗？你想让她成为你的女朋友吗？
Uh, no. Why do you ask?
呃，没有。你为什么要问这个？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语交流）
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] for the American citizens.
（模糊短语）给美国公民的。
You guys suck. Muslims rule, damn it. You guys just put on this act of freedom and stuff. But you guys are full of [BLEEP]. No, actually, Muslims are nice people. Give them a break. [SINGING] Give me a break. Break me off a piece of that Kit Kat bar.
你们真糟糕。穆斯林万岁，该死。你们这些人只会装作崇尚自由那一套。但你们根本全是鬼话。不，其实，穆斯林是好人。放过他们吧。（唱歌）放过我吧。给我一块奇巧巧克力棒。
You think I should come back to Pakistan.
你觉得我应该回到巴基斯坦。
Oh, yes, I think you should. Because it's your own country.
哦，是的，我觉得你应该。因为那是你自己的国家。
How old are you? 25? OK. So at 25, you decide whether you're going to be an American for the rest of your life, away from your friends, away from your family, away from your food, away from me, yes.
你多大了？25岁？好吧。所以在25岁，你决定你是要在余生里做一个美国人，远离朋友，远离家人，远离家乡美食，远离我，是的。
Or you want to be in Pakistan, maybe getting a little less salary. But then, who cares? You'll get used to that salary. If, once you go to the States, you're used to earning a high salary, you'll never come back to Pakistan and be happy. It's all about what you are used to in life. What you don't have, you don't miss. Right? So--
或者你想待在巴基斯坦，薪水可能稍微少一点。但那又怎样？你会习惯那个薪水的。如果一旦你去了美国，习惯了赚高薪，你永远也不会回来巴基斯坦并感到快乐。生活全看你习惯了什么。没有得到的，你就不会想念，对吧？所以——
So the two aunts and my mother are just-- they're always together. So it's always very [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]. It's never one of them alone. We cannot picture them alone, because both of them are bitter women. They're really, really funny. They're really, really cool, though, because they influence my mother a lot. And so my mother's aunt is trying to hook me up with one of her friend's daughters, whose name is [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]. So I'm going to ask [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
两个阿姨和我妈妈总是形影不离。所以总是不见（模糊短语）。从来没有她们其中一人单独出现的情况。我们无法想象她们单独的样子，因为她们俩都是苦涩的女人。不过她们真的很搞笑。她们真的很酷，因为她们对我妈妈影响很大。所以我妈妈的阿姨正试图把我介绍给她朋友的女儿，叫（模糊短语）。所以我要去问问（模糊短语）。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语交流）
She's saying she's from India, a rich family.
她说她来自印度，一个富裕的家庭。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语交流）
She's saying that the girl is very well-behaved. So what are you trying to say, that I'm not well-behaved?
她说那个女孩非常有教养。所以你想说什么，说我没有教养吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语交流）
She's like, she has knowledge of the world as well as the religions. So she's saying that-- very, very cute-looking. So I'm going to ask her right now if she can cook and stuff. [SPEAKING ARABIC]
她觉得她既有世俗知识，又有宗教修养。所以她说——长得非常、非常可爱。所以我现在要问她会不会做饭之类的。（阿拉伯语交流）
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语交流）
And she's giving me a menu of things that she can cook.
她正在给我列举她会做的菜。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语交流）
[SPEAKING ARABIC] She wants me to marry my first cousin, who basically lives in California. This is the amount of pressure I get from her.
（阿拉伯语交流）她想让我娶我的表妹，那个基本住在加州的人。这就是我从她那里感受到的压力。
So we never met [UNINTELLIGIBLE] daughter, who my aunts, [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE], were talking about, who was from India from a very, very rich family or something. And then they had set me up with another date. She had a British accent, and she came in a burqa and everything. And I never talked with her, because it was like a big group visiting together. But I wasn't interested.
所以我们从未见过阿姨提到的那个女儿，那个来自印度非常非常有钱家庭的人。然后她们又给我安排了另一次相亲。那个女孩有英国口音，裹着罩袍来的。我没怎么跟她说话，因为是一大群人聚在一起。但我没兴趣。
It's not that it doesn't appeal to me. It's just that I would have tried to have it on a mutual basis, that I would like the girl too. And of course I would want to know the girl more.
并不是它不吸引我。只是我希望能在一个相互的基础上进行，我也得喜欢那个女孩才行。当然，我会想多了解那个女孩。
OK, so we're going to this party right now, which I don't know how-- I'm here with my friend Hani. I can't even see anyone. Great, so this is the scene in Pakistan. The party scene.
好了，我们要去参加这个聚会了，我都不知道怎么——我和我的朋友哈尼在一起。我甚至看不清任何人。太棒了，这就是巴基斯坦的场景。派对场景。
There was a party tonight that I went to. And it was in a massive house. The entrance lounge was turned into a dance floor. And one of the rooms had large, large pillows all over the place. And everyone was either smoking up or making out. And there was alcohol and there was actually a bar. And there was a person mixing drinks.
今晚我去参加了一个派对。在一栋巨大的房子里。入口大厅变成了舞池。其中一个房间里到处都是巨大的垫子。每个人要么在抽烟，要么在亲热。那里有酒精，甚至有一个吧台。还有人在调酒。
I noticed there was a bottle of vodka and Pepsi and orange juice. And people were there, just looking all hip just with a glass. It was-- to be frank, it looked so artificial. I'm sure they must be having fun.
我注意到有一瓶伏特加，还有百事可乐和橙汁。人们就在那里，手里拿着玻璃杯，看起来很时髦。说实话，这看起来太虚假了。我相信他们一定玩得很开心。
Pakistan, being a very strict Muslim country-- alcohol is not sold publicly and stuff. And it's only a few shops that can sell it. But people do get around getting alcohol. It's unbelievable how liberal Pakistan has become, at least in this upscale party and stuff.
巴基斯坦是一个非常严格的穆斯林国家——酒精是不公开出售的。只有少数几家店可以卖。但人们确实有办法弄到酒。巴基斯坦变得如此自由化真是令人难以置信，至少在这些高端派对上是这样。
Hi. You guys like the party?
嗨。你们喜欢这个派对吗？
Yes.
是的。
Are you from Karachi?
你们是卡拉奇人吗？
Yes.
是的。
I'm not scaring you. I'm just asking.
我不是在吓唬你们。我只是在问问。
So we're at the party, and I saw these two girls. And I went up to them. I said, hey, what's up? Nice party, or something. And they're like, do we know you? Like, what? Because you don't go and talk to any girl at a party, because it's disrespectful. I had forgotten that. I forget what was the norms for a party there.
我们在派对上，我看到了这两个女孩。我走过去说，嘿，怎么了？很棒的派对，之类的话。她们说，我们认识你吗？就像，什么？因为你不能在派对上随便去跟女孩搭话，因为那是不礼貌的。我忘记了。我忘记了那里的派对规范。
Hi, I'm Hani's single friend. I scared her away.
嗨，我是哈尼的单身朋友。我把她吓跑了。
So if I am to move back to Pakistan, I'll probably-- in relative terms, I'll have more money. And I'll have more disposable income, because I'll have a car which is paid for. I'll have a house which is already there. I'll live with my parents, because that's how it goes. And I'll have to do none of housekeeping, clean my own room at the most. And I have to do no cooking at all. At all. And there are no groceries.
所以如果我搬回巴基斯坦，我大概——相对而言——会有更多的钱。我会有更多的可支配收入，因为我会有现成的车，现成的房子。我会和父母住在一起，因为情况就是这样。我根本不需要做家务，最多打扫一下自己的房间。根本不需要做饭。完全不需要。也不用买菜。
And the quality of life is probably going to be much, much better, compared to the quality of life to the US. Well, not probably. I'll probably make decent money. But it's always going to be like, I'll have to do my own laundry, I'll have to cook, I'll have to clean.
而且生活质量很可能比美国好得多。好吧，不是可能。我可能会赚到不错的钱。但总会是那样，我得自己洗衣服，自己做饭，自己打扫卫生。
I'm nowhere close to a decision, but I'm really surprised and confused, because it's just-- how do I choose? How do you make them talk the same language? How do you make your heart and head talk the same language?
我离做决定还差得远，但我真的很惊讶也很困惑，因为这简直是——我该怎么选择？怎么才能让它们说同一种语言？怎么才能让我的心和头脑说同一种语言？
So I'm hanging out with my cousin, Yusef Harman. So, tell me, being the eldest son, do you have any pressures on you from your family?
所以我和我的表弟尤瑟夫·哈曼待在一起。那么，告诉我，作为长子，你从家里感受到压力吗？
Oh, a lot. A lot. You get a lot of pressures. I mean, I can't do anything with asking my mother. All the time, she's after me. She's possessive about me. She doesn't want me to go for anyone else as yet, probably until the age of 27, or until all my sisters get married. So I just can't do anything I want to. That's how it is.
噢，很多。很多。压力很大。我是说，我什么都不能做，得问我妈妈。她一直盯着我。她对我很有占有欲。她可能不想让我找别人，直到27岁，或者直到我所有的姐妹都结婚。所以我根本不能做任何我想做的事。情况就是这样。
And I could really identify with all that because I was pretty much in the same boat that he is right now. Of course, every single decision is run by your parents, and you consult them. Let's say, you know, buying a car. If I have to buy a car after I graduate, I'll just probably go and buy whatever I want, or whatever falls in my budget. But if I'm back home, I need everyone to consent. And then my aunt would come back home, and she would say, oh, don't get black, get white. Get this, get that. It's all this.
我真的能感同身受，因为我就处在他现在的位置上。当然，每一个决定都要经过父母，你要咨询他们。比如，买车。如果我毕业后需要买车，我大概会直接去买任何我想要的，或者预算范围内的。但如果我回到了家，我需要所有人的同意。然后我阿姨会回到家，说，噢，别买黑色的，买白色的。买这个，买那个。全是这些事。
Almost everyone in my family made some argument like this.
我家里几乎每个人都提出了类似的论点。
I advise you to come to Pakistan and serve you country, to serve the country where you were born. Because America is already an advanced country, and they don't need any intellectual [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. But Pakistan requires many persons who are intellectual and highly educated.
我建议你回到巴基斯坦报效祖国，报效你出生的国家。因为美国已经是一个发达国家了，他们不需要任何知识分子（模糊词）。但巴基斯坦需要许多受过高等教育的知识分子。
That did sort of strike me. It's like Pakistan having a brain drain, like people study and then they stay back. And it does make me feel guilty because I do have to think-- I still love my country, I still have some sense of patriotism towards it. And I was born there. I can never change that.
这确实触动了我。这就像巴基斯坦正经历人才流失，人们去读书然后就留在那儿了。这确实让我感到内疚，因为我确实得思考——我依然爱我的国家，我对它仍有一种爱国心。我出生在那里。这一点我永远无法改变。
I'm driving back home after dropping my friend. And I'm just so in thought right now. And I don't know what to say. I'm really-- I'm 80% percent convinced that I should come back to Pakistan and work here and work for my country and of course my parents. It's such a hard decision. I'm so torn. I'm so torn. I don't know what to do.
送完朋友后我正在开车回家的路上。我脑子里思绪万千。我不知道该说什么。我真的——我有80%的把握决定应该回到巴基斯坦，在这里工作，为国家服务，当然还有为了父母。这真是一个艰难的决定。我非常纠结。我非常纠结。我不知道该怎么办。
So I left Karachi yesterday. And my mom was crying at the airport so much. And I was trying to hold back. I'm so homesick. I don't know what the hell I'm doing. I feel queasy in my stomach for some reason. Maybe it's the plane ride. I'm right over the top of Frankfurt, but all I can think of is Karachi. Karachi, Karachi, Karachi, Karachi, Karachi.
所以我昨天离开了卡拉奇。我妈妈在机场哭得好厉害。我一直在努力克制自己。我太想家了。我不知道我在干什么。我不知道为什么胃里一阵难受。可能是因为飞行。我正飞过法兰克福上空，但我脑子里想的全是卡拉奇。卡拉奇，卡拉奇，卡拉奇，卡拉奇，卡拉奇。
I got back today at 1:00. When I landed in Philadelphia, I felt so homesick for Karachi, because it's like, it's back to the grind, back to the routine life. I just kept thinking of my mom's cooking all of a sudden. The minute it touched down, the plane.
我今天一点钟回到了家。当我降落在费城时，我因为想念卡拉奇而感到难受，因为一切又回到了枯燥的循环，回到了常规生活。飞机一落地，我就突然开始想念妈妈做的饭了。
So it's been about a week and two days since I've been back in Philadelphia. And feels kind of strange to be here, because I feel like I'm starting from scratch, everything over again. I don't hang out as much as I used to before, when I was here, before I left. I don't know why. It's just kind of strange. Maybe because it's Ramadan, but I don't know. But I haven't seen many friends as much. I just feel I should be to myself. I'm a little down, I think.
回到费城已经一周多两天了。待在这里感觉有点奇怪，因为我觉得自己一切都要从头开始，所有事情又要重来一遍。我不像离开之前那样频繁地和朋友们出去玩了。我不知道为什么。这有点奇怪。也许是因为斋月，但我不知道。我没怎么见朋友。我只是觉得应该独处。我想我有点低落。
I've spoken to my parents ever since I got back. And my mom was like, so have you decided anything? So I told her, I just got here a week ago. And they try to call me every other day now. Usually it was like, you know, I would call them once a week, and they would call the next week. So it's like, every time I'm not home, she's like, so how come you didn't pick up your phone? And how come you weren't home? And how come-- where were you? God, man. Give me a break.
回来后我和父母通了电话。我妈说，那你决定了吗？所以我告诉她，我才刚回来一周。他们现在试图每隔一天就给我打电话。通常情况是，你知道的，我每周给他们打一次，下周他们再打过来。所以现在只要我不在家，她就会说，你怎么不接电话？你为什么不在家？你为什么——你去哪了？天哪，伙计。饶了我吧。
When I was leaving Karachi, when I was leaving the airport, she told me that, whatever you do, we'll be happy with it. But I really, really know that they really, really want me to come back.
我离开卡拉奇的时候，当我离开机场的时候，她告诉我，无论你做什么，我们都会很开心。但我真的真的知道，他们非常非常希望我回去。
So it's 21 December, 2004. And I got done with finals last Friday. And I've just been chilling ever since. And I've made my decision to stay. After a couple months of being back here in Philadelphia, in the States, everything fell into perspective.
现在是2004年12月21日。我上周五考完了最后一门课。从那之后我一直在放松。我已经做出了留下来的决定。在费城、在美国待了几个月后，一切都变得清晰了。
My feelings about Karachi faded as time passed and I as I got more involved and busy with my everyday life here. Of course, I was almost convinced at the time, when I was in Pakistan in Karachi, to stay back, because I literally went back after almost four years. Four years of not seeing my friends, my family, my cousins, my grandmother. And I loved it. And if I was literally waking up every morning thinking of my family, I would have gone back the second day.
我对卡拉奇的感觉随着时间流逝而淡去，我越来越投入到这里繁忙的日常生活中。当然，在卡拉奇的时候，我当时确实几乎被说服留下来，因为我真的是在快四年后才回去。四年没有见到朋友、家人、表兄弟、祖母。我爱那段时光。如果我每天早上醒来都在想家人，我第二天就会回去了。
But it's not like that. I do miss them. I miss them at a normal level. I don't terribly, terribly miss them. And once I got back here, I could picture my life back home when I went back. That scares me. I'll go back home, get a job, make a house, get married, have kids, have the in-laws over every Sunday for dinner. It'll just be the same monotonous routine over and over and over and over again. Maybe something else is going to happen. Maybe I'll go watch a movie in between somewhere.
但事实并非如此。我确实想念他们。是在正常程度上的想念。我没有到那种痛不欲生的程度。当我回到这里后，我能想象到如果回国后我的生活是什么样。那吓坏了我。我会回家，找份工作，盖房子，结婚，生子，每个周日邀请姻亲吃晚饭。那将是同样的单调乏味的生活，一遍又一遍，又一遍。也许会发生些别的事。也许中间能去看场电影。
And I could picture my life-- well, I couldn't picture it, but I could almost imagine it over here, and what I could be doing. And I imagine a house with white picket fences. No, I'm just kidding. Over here, everything is so exciting and everything so result-oriented right away that I can't imagine it. That's the excitement of it.
而我能想象到我的生活——好吧，我无法预见它，但我几乎能想象到在这里我能做些什么。我想象着带白色栅栏的房子。不，开个玩笑。在这里，一切都如此令人兴奋，而且立竿见影，这就是它的魅力所在。
Muhammad Kamran in Philadelphia. Coming up, two guys who aren't even officially faced with the choice, should they stay or should they go? They're told to go, leave their jobs, and they decide to stay. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
费城的穆罕默德·卡姆兰。接下来，两位甚至没有正式面临选择的年轻人，是该留下还是离开？他们被告知离开，放弃工作，但他们决定留下。一分钟后为您揭晓，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际公司，节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, stories of people deciding, should they stay or should they go? And we've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "Not Far From the Tree."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，是关于人们做出“留下还是离开”决定的故事。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“离树不远”。
There are some situations where it is pretty much taken for granted that you are not going to stay somewhere, like, for example, your boss tells you you no longer have a job. Sometimes, people were driven by a vision and they do not take that practical "no" to mean "no." Amy O'Leary reports.
有些情况下，你离开某处是理所当然的，比如，老板告诉你你失业了。有时，人们受愿景驱动，他们不会把那种现实的“不”当作最终结论。艾米·奥利里为您报道。
For Ron [UNINTELLIGIBLE], there was never any question. He wasn't going to leave. The project he'd been working on at Apple Computer had been cancelled. He was out of a job. But for Ron, it wasn't so simple. He was 27 and had been working on some version of the software for years, so he wasn't ready to just stop and go home.
对罗恩（模糊词）来说，根本没有疑问。他不会离开。他在苹果公司从事的项目被取消了。他失业了。但对罗恩来说，事情没那么简单。他27岁了，从事这个软件开发已经好几年了，所以他没准备好就此打住回家。
Having been totally embroiled in a project, working long hours and thinking about little else, to have it canceled and nothing come of it, it just seems like wasted effort. So I decided to stay and finish the part that I had been working on my own. And so I just kept showing up to work on it.
完全沉浸在一个项目中，长时间工作，满脑子想的都是它，结果项目取消了，一切化为泡影，这简直是浪费精力。所以我决定留下来，自己完成我正在做的那部分工作。于是我就一直去上班继续做这个。
The project that made him want to stay, to live off his savings and sneak into work every day for no money, probably won't sound very glamorous. It was a graphing calculator, a software program that would help math students make pictures of complicated equations. Now, to understand why this meant so much to Ron, you've got to understand two things. One, engineers are generally much more excited about advanced mathematics than the population at large. And two, this program wasn't just making little pencil lines on graph paper. It was generating gorgeous undulating three-dimensional pictures that changed as you altered the equations. If such a thing can be said, it made calculus sexy.
让他想要留下来，靠积蓄生活，每天偷偷溜进办公室不拿工资的项目，听起来可能没什么吸引力。那是一个图形计算器，一个能帮助数学学生制作复杂方程图像的软件。现在，要理解为什么这对罗恩意义如此重大，你必须理解两件事。第一，工程师通常对高等数学比普通大众更感兴趣。第二，这个程序不仅仅是在坐标纸上画小铅笔线。它生成的是绚丽起伏的三维图像，当你改变方程时，图像也会随之变化。如果可以这么说的话，它让微积分变得性感起来。
I knew that Ron was working despite the end of the project he was working on.
我知道尽管项目取消了，罗恩还是在工作。
That's Greg Robbins. He would drop by Ron's desk and was impressed with what he saw, so impressed that when Greg's contract ended, he signed on for Ron's project, which wasn't a job really as much as an extended six-month favor.
那是格雷格·罗宾斯。他会顺道去罗恩的办公桌看看，对所见印象深刻，印象深刻到当格雷格的合同结束时，他加入了罗恩的项目，这与其说是一份工作，不如说是一个长达六个月的人情。
I don't remember if we discussed explicitly, but I knew there was no money in this. I mean, doing math software is sort of like writing poetry. You hope that if you do a great job, you may touch someone. But you don't expect to make money off of it.
我不记得我们是否明确讨论过，但我知道这没有任何报酬。我是说，做数学软件就像写诗。你希望如果你做得好，可能会触动某人。但你并不指望靠它赚钱。
We just started literally sneaking into the building every day. We would show up in the parking lot, look around to see who was there, and as we were approaching the door we would time our walk so that we arrived at the entrance right behind someone. And they'd open the door and look at us and say, oh, hi, Ron. And we'd walk in with them, tailgating through the door, it's called.
我们开始每天偷偷潜入大楼。我们会出现在停车场，环顾四周看看谁在那里，当我们靠近大门时，我们会掌握好时间，这样我们就能在别人后面到达入口。他们会开门看到我们说，噢，嗨，罗恩。我们就跟着他们走进去，这叫“尾随进入”。
Their tactics was-- pretty much, as far as I saw-- when I showed up, I'd let them in.
他们的策略是——据我所见——当我出现时，我就会让他们进去。
Tim Dereks was an engineer who was actually paid to come to the office. I don't know whether it's because I was one of the few guys they knew, or whether they just happened to come in about the same time I did, but I was probably letting them in at least a couple of times a week.
蒂姆·德雷克斯是一位真正领薪水来办公室工作的工程师。我不知道是因为我是他们认识的少数几个人之一，还是因为他们恰好和我同时到达，但我大概一周至少会有几次让他们进去。
The people in the adjacent offices knew we were there.
邻近办公室的人都知道我们在那里。
Again, Greg.
又是格雷格。
Frequently they knew what we were working on. If anyone ever came to us and asked, we were more than happy to talk about it. Sometimes we would leave out certain details like the fact that it wasn't a real project.
他们经常知道我们在做什么。如果有人过来问，我们非常乐意聊聊。有时我们会遗漏一些细节，比如这不是一个正规项目。
Occasionally, people would ask me, do you work here? And I'd say, no. And then they would assume, oh, that means you're a contractor. And I'd explain, well, actually, no. And then they'd say, but then, who's paying you? And I'd tell them, no one. At which point, they'd get it. They'd look at me and say, how do you live? And I'd explain, I live simply. And then they'd get this really interesting look on her face, and say, but what are you doing here?
偶尔会有人问我，你在这里工作吗？我会说，不。然后他们会想，噢，那意味着你是承包商。我会解释，嗯，其实不是。然后他们会说，那谁付钱给你？我告诉他们，没人。这时他们就明白了。他们会看着我说，那你怎么生活？我会解释，我生活得很简单。然后他们脸上会出现这种非常有趣的表情，说，那你在这里干什么？
What they were doing was very quietly, and very efficiently, building a perfect piece of software. There weren't any meetings, any office politics, or managers. They never compromised. They never fought. It was the fantasy version of how great work could be if management just evaporated.
他们所做的是非常安静且高效地构建了一个完美的软件。没有会议，没有办公室政治，没有经理。他们从未妥协。他们从未争吵。如果管理层直接蒸发，工作能有多棒，这就是那种幻想版本。
Occasionally, I would tell people-- I mean, it's true. I did tell people that I reported to Ron. Ron would tell people that he reported to me. In a corporate hierarchy, that's all someone wants to hear. If they know who you report to, then they can fit you into the big picture.
偶尔，我会告诉别人——我是说，这是真的。我确实告诉过别人我向罗恩汇报。罗恩会告诉别人他向我汇报。在公司层级中，这就是别人想听到的。如果他们知道你向谁汇报，那他们就能把你塞进大局里。
I slipped up at one point when someone from Facilities came to explain to us that they were moving new engineers into our offices. I was naive. I told her the same story I told everyone else. She just explained, that's completely inappropriate. She had our badges canceled and expected us to just clear out the offices and leave the building. So we just moved to another set of offices that were empty.
有一次我失误了，当时行政部门的人来解释说他们要把新的工程师搬进我们的办公室。我太天真了。我告诉了她我告诉其他人的那个故事。她只是解释说，这完全不合适。她取消了我们的证件，并期望我们就清理办公室离开大楼。所以我们就搬到了另一处空着的办公室。
For a while, it was hard to find space. They kept getting displaced by real employees. But then big layoffs hit Apple. And suddenly there were entire hallways of empty offices for the taking. At the same time, news about the project was getting around. Among some engineers at Apple, Ron and Greg's graphing calculator was becoming a kind of underground cause celebre.
有一段时间，很难找到空间。我们不断被真正的员工取代。但后来苹果公司发生大规模裁员。突然间，到处都是整条走廊空置的办公室供人占用。与此同时，关于这个项目的消息传开了。在苹果公司的一些工程师中，罗恩和格雷格的图形计算器正成为一种地下传奇。
Folks knew about us. And they would literally come to our office at midnight and slip a machine under the door and tell me, OK, Ron, officially this machine doesn't exist. Make sure no one opens the top to look inside. Whatever you do, don't take it out of the building. And if anyone asks, I don't know you.
大家都知道我们。他们真的会在午夜来到我们的办公室，把机器从门底下塞进来，告诉我，好吧，罗恩，官方来说这台机器不存在。确保没人打开顶盖看里面。无论你做什么，都不要把它带出大楼。如果有人问起，我不认识你。
When an engineer slipped us not one but two hardware prototypes, that just amazed us.
当一位工程师不仅偷偷给我们一台，而是两台硬件原型机时，这真的让我们惊呆了。
The hardware prototype was Apple's newest computer, still in development.
硬件原型机是苹果公司最新的计算机，还在开发中。
We had something that was extremely hard to get for the employees at the company. That was extremely rare, because they were hand-built. It was hard to believe that something which wasn't a real project could have hardware that many real projects would die for.
我们拥有了公司员工极难获得的东西。这非常罕见，因为它们是手工制造的。很难相信，一个非正规项目竟然能拥有许多正规项目梦寐以求的硬件。
There was a practical reason that people were sneaking this equipment to them. Apple was about to unveil a brand-new machine, the Power PC. The future of the company was riding on it, and Apple's employees were so busy making sure that their old software would run on the new computer that nobody was creating new software-- nobody, that is, except Ron and Greg, whose flashy graphing calculator would be the company's only way to demonstrate the groundbreaking speed of their new machines.
人们偷偷把设备给他们是有实际原因的。苹果即将推出一款全新的机器，Power PC。公司的未来寄托在它身上，苹果的员工忙着确保他们的旧软件能在新电脑上运行，没有人去开发新软件——没有人，除了罗恩和格雷格，他们炫酷的图形计算器将成为公司展示新机器突破性速度的唯一方式。
But Greg and Ron faced a problem, the problem, the obstacle that from the beginning seemed completely insurmountable.
但格雷格和罗恩面临一个问题，那个从一开始看起来完全不可逾越的障碍。
When we started undertaking this, we weren't thinking about, how are we going to get in the building? We're thinking about, how are we going to get it out on a million machines? You just don't get software built into the machine without the company's blessing.
当我们开始做这件事时，我们并没有想，我们要怎么进入大楼？我们在想，我们要怎么把它装进一百万台机器里？没有公司的允许，你是不可能把软件内置进机器的。
And then, in the dark of night, the solution to their problem walked right in the door.
然后，在暗夜里，他们的问题的解决方案主动找上门来。
An engineer came into my office at two in the morning, and said to me, there's a factory out in Cork, Ireland. And one of the last steps in the production of the machines is to copy from what's called the golden master hard disk onto each hard disk in the factory before it gets put in the box. He said, I create the golden master hard disk.
一位工程师在凌晨两点走进我的办公室，对我说，在爱尔兰科克有一家工厂。机器生产的最后步骤之一是在装箱前，将所谓的黄金母盘硬盘拷贝到工厂里的每一块硬盘上。他说，我创建了那个黄金母盘硬盘。
You get that? Picture, like, the wizard from Lord of the Rings standing there in a halo of light.
你懂吗？想象一下，《指环王》里的巫师站在光环中。
I create the golden master hard disk. In a very real and pragmatic sense, I decide what does and doesn't ship. This is the date that I FedEx the disk. If you come to my office that evening, before anyone else notices, it will be boxed in 30,000 units in the factory.
我创建了那个黄金母盘硬盘。在一个非常现实和务实的意义上，我决定了什么能装船运送，什么不能。这是我联邦快递磁盘的日期。如果你那天晚上在别人注意到之前来到我的办公室，它就会被装入工厂的3万台设备中。
Perfect plan. Only, after those first 30,000 computers came off the assembly line, Apple execs would notice that something had been slipped onto their machines, and then there's no telling what would happen, or who they would go after. So Ron and Greg came up with a different plan. It was probably the gutsiest, most radical ideal of all. Schedule a meeting, bring in management, and admit everything.
完美的计划。只是，在那最初的3万台电脑下线后，苹果高管会发现他们的机器里被塞进了东西，到时候就不知道会发生什么，或者他们会去找谁算账。所以罗恩和格雷格想出了一个不同的计划。这可能是所有想法中最勇敢、最激进的一个。安排会议，叫来管理层，坦白一切。
Ron [UNINTELLIGIBLE] showed up one day and said, hey, I have something neat to show you.
罗恩（模糊词）有一天出现说，嘿，我有样好东西给你们看。
Don Norman would soon become a VP at Apple.
唐·诺曼不久后成为苹果公司的副总裁。
And Ron showed his fantastic graphing calculator, where you could just sort of plug in the equation. You could play with things. You could do things that were never possible before. And I said, wow, we've got to ship this in every Macintosh. And Ron said, well, that's just the problem. Because, well, it turned out that Ron didn't exist.
罗恩展示了他那出色的图形计算器，你可以随手输入方程。你可以摆弄各种东西。你可以做以前从未可能做到的事情。我说，哇，我们必须在每一台麦金塔电脑里预装这个。罗恩说，嗯，问题就在这儿。因为，嗯，结果证明罗恩并不存在。
Not in the company records, anyway. But here he was, demonstrating the calculator in front of 15 managers who watched, captivated, for more than an hour as Ron let the software speak for itself.
至少在公司记录里不存在。但他就在那里，在15位经理面前演示计算器，他们看得入迷，超过一个小时，罗恩让软件为自己代言。
They all nodded and they said, that's great. That's perfect. This exactly demonstrates everything we've been talking about for months. Why didn't we hear about this before? Who do you work for? Why didn't they tell us?
他们都点头说，太棒了。太完美了。这完全证明了我们几个月来一直谈论的一切。为什么我们以前没听说过这个？你为谁工作？为什么他们没告诉我们？
At which point, I told them, well, actually the project was cancelled three months ago. I don't actually work here. And everyone laughed and I thought I was kidding and said, no, really, who do you work for? And then there was a moment of awkward silence until they realized I was serious. Then they told me, well, we really want to ship this. Don't repeat your story. We'll figure something out. And at that point, things got really weird.
这时，我告诉他们，嗯，其实这个项目三个月前就被取消了。我实际上不在这里工作。大家都笑了，以为我在开玩笑，说，不，说真的，你为谁工作？然后有一阵尴尬的沉默，直到他们意识到我是认真的。然后他们告诉我，嗯，我们真的很想发布这个。别再说你的故事了。我们会想办法的。在那一刻，事情变得非常诡异。
The folks in charge have adopted us. They do want to ship this. And they're assigning people to work on it. And at the same time that paid employees are working on it, I'm in the middle of managing all of this while Greg and I are still sneaking into the building.
负责的人收养了我们。他们确实想发布这个。他们正在指派人员参与其中。与此同时，当领薪水的员工在为此工作时，我还在负责管理这一切，而格雷格和我仍然偷偷溜进大楼。
In the end, after six months of work, the software was so reliable, so uncrashable, that it became the software Apple used to test sick computers. If your machine wasn't working, but it wasn't clear how serious things were, Apple Technical Support would tell you to run the graphing calculator overnight. Then, if your computer crashed the uncrashable graphing calculator, you officially had a hardware problem.
最终，经过六个月的工作，这个软件非常可靠，绝不会崩溃，以至于它成了苹果公司用来测试故障电脑的软件。如果你的机器出问题了，但不知道严重程度，苹果技术支持会让你运行图形计算器过夜。然后，如果你的电脑导致永不崩溃的图形计算器崩溃了，你官方上就是硬件出了问题。
It was also so curious and impressive, with its shifting, spinning, multicolored shapes, that Apple used it in sales demonstrations and computer stores simply to draw people over to the machines. So after all this, the graphing calculator was installed on not just a million machines, but on more than 20 million Apple computers worldwide.
它也因其不断变化、旋转、五彩斑斓的形状而令人好奇和印象深刻，苹果公司在销售演示和电脑商店里使用它，仅仅是为了吸引人们靠近机器。所以经过这一切，图形计算器不仅安装在一百万台机器上，而且安装在全球超过2000万台苹果电脑上。
Ron and Greg eventually got a modest check for their work and went on to other jobs elsewhere. For years, Ron only told the story at parties, but recently, he posted it on the internet, where he received a flood of responses from other software engineers. Some said Ron and Greg were losers, that they were taken advantage of.
罗恩和格雷格最终为他们的工作得到了一张适度的支票，并去了别处找了别的工作。多年来，罗恩只在派对上讲这个故事，但最近，他把它贴到了互联网上，在那里他收到了来自其他软件工程师的大量回应。有些人说罗恩和格雷格是失败者，他们被占了便宜。
I was surprised when I first heard someone say that we had been used by the company, because for us, we were doing what we wanted to do, to have created something that people remember, that they can say, yeah, when I first saw that, I was blown away.
当我第一次听到有人说我们被公司利用了时，我很惊讶，因为对我们来说，我们是在做我们想做的事，创造了人们记得的东西，他们会说，是的，当我第一次看到那个时，我惊呆了。
You know, that's just an immense achievement.
你知道，那简直是一个巨大的成就。
Again, Tim Dereks, who'd been letting them in the door for months.
又是蒂姆·德雷克斯，他连续几个月让他们进门。
And so, true, from one perspective he did that for Apple for free. But on the other perspective, Apple did this for him, and it's something he couldn't have gotten otherwise. I think if you offered an independent filmmaker-- you know what, we're not going to give you any money. You're going to have to beg, borrow, or steal all the equipment, but you make a one-minute film and we'll air it during the Super Bowl. I don't know of any true artist filmmaker who wouldn't jump at that chance.
所以，确实，从一个角度看，他免费为苹果做了这件事。但从另一个角度看，苹果为他做了这个，这是他无法通过其他途径获得的。我想如果你给一位独立电影人——你知道吗，我们不会给你任何钱。你必须乞求、借贷或偷窃所有设备，但你拍一部一分钟的短片，我们会在超级碗期间播放它。我不知道有哪位真正的艺术家电影人不会抓住这个机会。
This whole story appeals to our ideas about what a job can be, that if we do we want, if we do what we love, and do it our way, that eventually we'll be proven right and the whole company will be better for it. But not so fast. It's a fluke when it works out this well. Even Ron and Greg don't think it could happen to them again. They're still writing software, though. Ron works for himself, Greg for another company. These days, they both get paid. To be honest, Greg says, it's not quite as fun as it used to be. He swipes his badge in in the mornings, and he never stays nights.
整个故事呼应了我们对工作可以是什么样子的构想，即如果我们做我们想要的，如果我们做我们热爱的，并按我们的方式去做，最终我们会证明是对的，整个公司也会变得更好。但这别想得太容易。当事情进展得这么顺利时，这是一个侥幸。即使是罗恩和格雷格也不认为它能再次发生在他们身上。不过，他们还在编写软件。罗恩为自己工作，格雷格为另一家公司工作。这些天，他们都有报酬。说实话，格雷格说，它没有以前那么有趣了。他早上刷卡进入，晚上从来不留下来。
Amy O'Leary in New York City.
纽约市的艾米·奥利里。
Act Three, "Because I'm the Mommy, That's Why."
第三幕，“因为我是妈妈，所以就这样”。
Virginia Holman's mom became schizophrenic in the '70s, when understanding and diagnosis and treatment were not as forthcoming as they are today. We end our show with this story, how Virginia and her sister were dragged along on a "Should I Go" sort of mission. Actress Catherine Keener reads.
弗吉尼亚·霍尔曼的母亲在70年代患上了精神分裂症，当时对这种病的理解、诊断和治疗不像今天这么先进。我们以这个故事结束我们的节目，讲述弗吉尼亚和她妹妹是如何被拖入某种“我该走吗”的任务的。女演员凯瑟琳·基纳为您朗读。
Until my mother told us, my sister and I hadn't a clue we were being kidnapped. I simply came home from school one afternoon, and my mother told me we were going to our cottage in Kecatan for a couple of days. She said my father would join us there.
直到我母亲告诉我们，我和妹妹根本不知道我们被绑架了。我那天下午放学回家，母亲告诉我我们要去基卡坦的小屋待几天。她说父亲会在那里和我们会合。
There was nothing in her manner that made me uneasy. I do recall that she seemed especially happy. Though I didn't realize it at the time, the voices in her head were telling her that she had been chosen to help serve her country in a secret war. Her mission was to set up a field hospital at the cottage. Hundreds of orphaned children would travel to our cottage at night. We were to treat their injuries and evacuate them to safety.
她的举止没什么让我不安的。我确实记得她看起来特别开心。虽然我当时没意识到，她脑子里的声音告诉她，她被选中在秘密战争中为国效力。她的任务是在小屋里建立一所野战医院。成百上千的孤儿会在晚上来到我们的小屋。我们要治疗他们的伤口并将他们疏散到安全地带。
But right then, getting into the car, I knew none of that. I just sang along with the songs on the radio as we drove out of Virginia Beach. Our dog Ralph hung his huge gray head out of the passenger-side window.
但当时，上车时，我对此一无所知。我们驶出弗吉尼亚海滩时，我只是跟着收音机里的歌一起唱。我们的狗拉尔夫把巨大的灰色脑袋伸出副驾驶的车窗。
"Goodbye, Oyster Point Village," my mother called as we left our townhouse court. "Goodbye, pool. Goodbye, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Goodbye, Tammy Sugarman's house. Goodbye. Goodbye." She was ecstatic.
“再见，牡蛎角村，”我们离开联排别墅区时母亲大喊。“再见，游泳池。再见，（模糊词）。再见，塔米·萨格曼家。再见。再见。”她欣喜若狂。
When we hit the Hampton Roads tunnel, John Denver was singing "Thank God I'm a Country Boy," and my mother sang louder and harder than I'd ever seen, waving her head in the wind, laughing so hard tears squeezed out of the corners of her eyes. My sister Emma was in the back seat, clapping her hands and growling, her latest trick. She sounded like a puppy. "Here we go, Gingy," my mother announced as we descended into the mouth of the tunnel. I held my breath and began to count to see how long I could last. The car went dark. The radio signal disappeared. And we went under.
当我们穿过汉普顿路隧道时，约翰·丹佛正在唱着“感谢上帝我是个乡村男孩”，母亲唱得比我见过的任何时候都更大声、更卖力，在风中挥舞着头，笑得眼角都挤出了泪水。我妹妹艾玛在后座拍手咆哮，这是她最新的把戏。她听起来像只小狗。“我们走吧，金吉，”隧道入口处，母亲宣布。我屏住呼吸开始数数，看看我能坚持多久。车里一片漆黑。收音机信号消失了。我们潜入隧道。
The cottage is a tiny place, a 700-square-foot cabin constructed by my grandfather for short-term summer inhabitancy. Its foundation is two inches of poured cement that also serves as the floor. The metal shower stall was purchased at a battleship auction.
小屋是个很小的地方，是一个由我祖父建造的700平方英尺的木屋，用于短暂的避暑居住。它的地基是两英寸浇筑的水泥，也用作地板。金属淋浴隔间是在战列舰拍卖会上买的。
"First," my mother declared, "we've been ordered to sanitize the premises." She opens the hood of the Volkswagen and pulls out buckets and bottles of ammonia.
“首先，”母亲宣布，“我们被命令净化场所。”她打开大众汽车的引擎盖，拿出水桶和氨水瓶。
"What do you mean, we've been ordered? Who ordered us?"
“什么叫我们被命令？谁命令我们的？”
"That's for me to know, missy. You just do as you're told. You take orders, or they'll court martial you and put you in jail. And I am your superior." My mother has never spoken quite this way before. On any other day, I wouldn't hesitate to fight her, but today I do as I am told.
“那是我的事，小丫头。你照做就是了。你服从命令，否则他们会送你上军事法庭并把你关进监狱。我是你的长官。”母亲从来没这样说过话。换做平时，我肯定会毫不犹豫地反抗她，但今天我照做了。
Mother and I throw sitting covers over the sofa and chairs and set Emma down with a few toys. We haul the mattresses from the bunk beds into the sun to bleach out the mildew. Mom unpacks two small cans of paint and two new brushes, and we carefully paints the glass of each window in the cottage solid black.
母亲和我把沙发和椅子套上座套，让艾玛坐下玩一会儿玩具。我们把双层床上的床垫拿到太阳下晒，去除霉味。妈妈打开两小罐油漆和两把新刷子，我们小心翼翼地把小屋每扇窗户的玻璃都漆成了纯黑色。
"Now," Mom says, "it's like our very own secret hideout. When we're here at night, we could have the lights on and no one will know." I wonder how much turpentine it's going to take to clean the windows again.
“现在，”妈妈说，“这就像我们自己的秘密基地了。晚上待在这里，我们可以开着灯，没人会知道。”我想知道重新清理这些窗户需要多少松节油。
My cousin Darby runs down from her house two acres over. My mother's brother, Chuck, built his house on his share of the family property, just to the north of us. To our south is the home of my dead grandmother's sister, Purlene.
我的堂妹达比从两英亩外她家跑过来。母亲的兄弟查克在家庭财产中属于他的那部分上建了房子，就在我们北边。我们南边是我已故祖母的妹妹珀琳的家。
"Are you down for the weekend?" Darby asks me. Mom is in the bathroom, arranging the shelves. "Can you play?" Darby is 11. I toss my broom and dustpan in the corner and head out the door the way I always do when we're down at the cottage for a weekend, but Mom comes after us.
“你们周末下来住吗？”达比问我。妈妈正在浴室里整理架子。“可以玩吗？”达比11岁。我把扫帚和簸箕扔在角落里，像往常去小屋度周末一样准备出门，但妈妈追了过来。
"Darby, we've important work to do today, and Gingy must stay here to care for young Emma. I'm so sorry."
“达比，我们今天有重要的工作要做，金吉必须留在这里照顾年幼的艾玛。真抱歉。”
My mother is speaking with a British accent all of a sudden. We think she's making a joke, and so Darby and I crack up and keep going. My mother grabs my arm and begins dragging me back to the house, pulling me backward through the pine needles. Darby starts crying and yells at my mother, and then flees for her house.
母亲突然说起了英国口音。我们以为她在开玩笑，达比和我大笑起来继续走。母亲抓住我的胳膊，开始把我拖回房子，拽着我在松针地上倒着走。达比开始哭，冲着我母亲大喊，然后逃回了她家。
Once we're inside the cottage, Mom bolts the door. "Can't you see what we have to do?" she says. "Other people will not understand. You cannot talk about  the secret war. You have been called to help. This is very important. You will do what I say."
进了小屋后，妈妈插上了门。“看不出来我们必须要做什么吗？”她说，“别人不会理解的。你不能谈论秘密战争。你被征召来帮忙。这很重要。你要听我的话。”
I feel mother wrap her arms around me, and even though I struggle to get free, I can't. "I love you. You know that," she says. "I would never do this if I didn't love you. You must help. This is important. You will understand."
我感到母亲搂住我，即使我挣扎着想逃脱，也没能成功。“我爱你。你知道的，”她说，“如果不是因为爱你，我永远不会这么做。你必须帮忙。这很重要。你会理解的。”
My mother begins keeping notebooks, enormous five-subject spiral-bound books where she records the progress of the secret war. I sneak a look, but her notes are about as interesting as reading someone's old grocery list. What's exciting is that Mom is always on guard. We are always to be on the lookout for clues. They can be broadcast to her telepathically via the CIA, or they can appear in the environment. She takes pictures from art books and magazines, along with the things we've gathered on our walks, and glues them to nearly every surface in the house.
母亲开始记笔记本，那是巨大的五科螺旋装订本，她记录秘密战争的进展。我偷偷看了一眼，但她的笔记读起来就像别人的旧购物单一样无聊。令人兴奋的是母亲总是处于警惕状态。我们总是要寻找线索。它们可以通过中央情报局以心灵感应方式广播给她，或者它们会出现在环境中。她从艺术书籍和杂志上撕下图片，连同我们在散步时收集的东西，把它们贴在房子里几乎每一个表面上。
Clues also come in other forms, and I discover the thing that every treasure hunter or private eye must know, that once you have a bit of code, a sign, a clue, it's impossible to stop looking for more. It's addictive. The world as you know it ceases to exist and is replaced with a universe bottomless with intrigue. For me, it is like being Nancy Drew, without the red sports car or any real case to crack.
线索也以其他形式出现，我发现了每个寻宝者或私家侦探都必须知道的事情，那就是一旦你有了代码、符号或线索，就无法停止寻找更多。这会让人上瘾。你所知道的世界不复存在，被一个充满阴谋、深不见底的宇宙所取代。对我来说，这就像是南茜·朱尔，没有红色跑车，也没有任何真正的案件要破。
Mother, Emma, and I take long walks through the marsh, looking for signs. Mother picks up a dull aluminum can and tosses it back down, but a piece of yellow nylon rope tangled in a blackberry bush means something. I run through the sea grass, bringing her fragments of things to pass judgment on-- an old medicine bottle, boiled crab shell, a moldy corn husk doll. What do these things mean?
母亲、艾玛和我去沼泽地长途漫步，寻找迹象。母亲捡起一个暗淡的铝罐又扔了回去，但一根缠在黑莓丛里的黄色尼龙绳意味着什么。我在海草中奔跑，带着碎片去让她判断——一个旧药瓶、煮过的蟹壳、一个发霉的玉米皮娃娃。这些东西意味着什么？
"Get your pack. They're coming."
“拿上你的包。他们来了。”
I sit up and Mom is dressed in blue jeans and a dark jacket. The clocks read 3:33. It's weird to see all the numbers lined up like that, all the same. Mom says, "Tonight's a test run. Night maneuvers."
我坐起来，妈妈穿着蓝色牛仔裤和深色夹克。钟表显示3:33。看到所有的数字像那样排成一行，一模一样，真怪。妈妈说，“今晚是一次测试运行。夜间机动。”
"I don't want to do night maneuvers," I tell her and roll back under the covers.
“我不想进行夜间机动，”我告诉她，翻身缩回被窝。
"Oh, no, you don't. We have to do this tonight. Get your clothes on."
“噢，不，你必须参加。我们今晚必须这样做。把衣服穿上。”
I pull on my brown Toughskins and a green t-shirt. The night air is soft and the half-moon lights up the sky. Mom carries Emma out to the car and lays her in the backseat with a blanket. "Leave her here. You'll just wake her," I say.
我穿上棕色的Toughskins裤子和一件绿色T恤。夜空气很柔和，半月照亮了天空。妈妈抱着艾玛上车，给她盖上毯子放进后座。“把她留在这里吧。你会吵醒她的，”我说。
"She'll be awake when the real thing happens, so she comes."
“当真正的事情发生时她是会醒着的，所以她得跟我们去。”
We get in the car and Mom takes a scarf out of her pocket. "Now I'm going to blindfold you. No peeking. Promise." I pull it down around my neck. I find myself wondering how long you can breathe in the trunk of a Volkswagen. I push these thoughts aside.
我们上车，妈妈从口袋里拿出一块围巾。“现在我要蒙住你的眼睛。不许偷看。答应我。”我把它拉下来缠在脖子上。我发现自己想知道在大众汽车的后备箱里能呼吸多久。我把这些想法抛在脑后。
"Here's the deal, Gingy. You just don't know how any of this is going to happen, pumpkin. When the war starts, someone could be taking you out to see the children, someone who is to keep their arrival point a secret, even from you. There could also be a kidnapping, someone who takes you away because they don't want you to help the war children. The thing is, you never know who's who. That's why we never talk to anyone about the secret war. That's why you have to always pay attention." She pulls the scarf back over my eyes.
“这是交易，金吉。你只是不知道这一切会怎么发生，小南瓜。当战争开始时，有人可能会带你去看孩子们，那个要对到达点保密的人，甚至对你也要保密。还可能会有绑架，有人把你带走，因为他们不想让你帮助战时儿童。关键是，你永远不知道谁是谁。这就是为什么我们从不和任何人谈论秘密战争。这就是为什么你必须时刻注意。”她把围巾拉过我的眼睛。
I close my eyes under the blindfold and lay out a map in my head. Mom starts the car. I know that my starting point is our driveway and I pay attention to the turns the car makes, trying to anticipate where we're going, but making a list in my head. Left turn out of driveway, right turn soon after.
我闭上眼在蒙眼布下，在脑海中铺开地图。妈妈启动了车。我知道起点是我们的车道，我注意车子的转向，试图预测我们要去哪里，但在心里列了个清单。车道左转，不久后右转。
We seem to drift to the left. I hear gravel and sand. Then we turn around, back onto the street to the right. Then another left. Uphill a bit, gear shift, turn around. We stop. Mom helps me out of the car. Frogs and cicadas, off the road, scrub grass and weeds against the legs of my jeans. Down a hill, and then we're next to the water.
我们似乎向左漂移。我听到碎石和沙子的声音。然后我们掉头，回到街上向右转。然后又是左转。上坡一点，换挡，掉头。我们停了下来。妈妈扶我下车。青蛙和蝉鸣，路外，灌木杂草蹭着我牛仔裤的腿。下坡，然后我们就到了水边。
Mom has her hand on my shoulder and walks behind me. We're in the woods. The air is cool on my face, and then I could smell the pine needles.
妈妈把手搭在我的肩膀上，走在我后面。我们在树林里。空气吹在脸上很凉，然后我能闻到松针的味道。
We stop, and I hear Mom rustle through her pack. "Your job is to get back to the duck blind. I'll be waiting for you there." She lights a match for her cigarette, a hiss and then the sharp sulfur smell. Her hand is back on my shoulder and we keep walking. I have to keep reminding myself to come back to the list in my head, to focus on this one thing. My mind wanders.
我们停了下来，我听到妈妈在包里翻找。“你的任务是回到猎鸭掩体。我会坐在那里等你。”她划了一根火柴点烟，嘶的一声，紧接着是刺鼻的硫磺味。她的手又搭在我的肩膀上，我们继续走。我必须不断提醒自己回到脑子里的清单上，专注于这一件事。思绪乱飘。
Then Mom's gone. I realize it just like that. There's no hand on my shoulder, no one pushing me forward, just my own movement. I pull the blindfold down around my neck and wait for my eyes to adjust. From "How To Survive In the Woods," I remember the best way to look for tracks is to look for something irregular in the landscape. Pine needles have fallen here for years, animals come through, deer and dogs, birds. Once I start looking, it's easy enough to see the line of our path. I shuffle my feet all the way. I should remember to do that when the war really happens.
然后妈妈不见了。我就这样意识到了。肩膀上没有手了，没有人推我前进了，只有我自己的动作。我把蒙眼布拉到脖子上，等待眼睛适应光线。从《野外生存指南》里，我记得寻找足迹最好的方法是寻找景观中不规则的东西。松针在这里掉落多年了，动物们会经过，鹿、狗、鸟。一旦我开始寻找，看清我们路径的线索就很容易了。我一路蹭着脚走。当战争真正发生时我得记得这么做。
I follow the trail to the road. Mom's dropped me off at the end of beach road. Home is a straight-shot half-mile walk. I stop at the cottage to get a glass of milk before I go to the duck blind. Mom's stretched out on the sofa. "The mosquitoes are awful out there," she yawns. "What time is it?"
我沿着小路走到大路上。妈妈把我扔在了海滩路尽头。回家是一条直线的半英里路。我停在小屋喝了一杯牛奶才去猎鸭掩体。妈妈正伸展身体躺在沙发上。“蚊子在外面太可怕了，”她打了个哈欠。“几点了？”
"4:30."
“4:30。”
"Not bad for your first time."
“第一次表现不错。”
"Thanks," I say.
“谢谢，”我说。
"Sit down with me?"
“坐下陪我一会儿？”
I sit beside her on the sofa and she strokes my hair.
我在沙发上坐在她身边，她抚摸着我的头发。
Should I recall this time as horrifying? I don't. At the time, my mother's actions and behavior were incomprehensible. There was no context in which I could place the bizarre events that were occurring. If there was ever a moment when things changed, the move to Kecatan was it. At the time, I honestly believed that I could run away if I wanted. Like the war children my mother expected, I could be an orphan.
我应该把这段时间记为恐怖吗？并没有。当时，我母亲的行为举止是无法理解的。我无法将发生的奇怪事件置于任何情境中。如果事情发生改变有一刻的话，那就是搬到基卡坦。当时，我真心相信如果我想的话我可以逃跑。像母亲预期的那些战时儿童一样，我也可以成为孤儿。
Of course, I didn't run away. I stayed. And because I stayed, I thought it meant I wanted to stay. Even at the age of nine, staying with my mother felt like a choice. Once I had made that choice, I was with my mother in her mission to set up the hospital.
当然，我没有逃跑。我留下了。因为我留下了，我以为这意味着我想留下。即使在九岁时，和母亲待在一起也感觉像是一种选择。一旦我做出了那个选择，我就和母亲一起执行她建立医院的任务了。
I decided that I would believe in the secret war. My mother's delusion became my delusion, not so much a choice as a simple fact. It was a way not to lose her, yes, but I guess it was also more fun for a nine-year-old tomboy to believe she was chosen to aid in a secret war than to believe she was being held hostage by her mother.
我决定我要相信秘密战争。母亲的妄想成了我的妄想，与其说是选择，不如说是一个简单的事实。这是一种不失去她的方法，是的，但我想这也是一个九岁的小男孩婆相信她被选中去辅助秘密战争，而不是相信她被母亲当作人质，这会更有趣。
"Where were you, those early months we were down at the cottage?" I asked my father on the phone, 25 years later. "What were you thinking?"
“我们在基卡坦的那几个月，你都在哪？”25年后我在电话里问父亲。“你在想什么？”
"I was in Virginia Beach, working." His voice halts. I don't budge. I refuse to fill the silence he has left on the other end of the line. "I don't know what to tell you. I don't know what I thought. Things were so bad, and your mother loved Kecatan. I thought maybe it might be the one thing that would help her. Of course," he says dryly, "that wasn't the case."
“我在弗吉尼亚海滩工作。”他的声音停顿了。我没有退缩。我拒绝填补他留在电话另一端的沉默。“我不知道该怎么告诉你。我不知道我在想什么。事情太糟糕了，而你母亲爱基卡坦。我想也许这可能是唯一能帮助她的事。当然，”他干巴巴地说，“事实并非如此。”
Over the years, it's been easy for me to lose track of the fact of my father's loss of my mother. He loved her too. Now I can't speak, I can't find my way through the questions on my list. They all start to sound like one small cry of why, why, why? Why didn't you do something?
多年来，我很容易忽略父亲失去母亲这一事实。他也爱她。现在我说不出话来，找不到方法理清我清单上的问题。它们听起来都像是一声小小的哭喊：为什么，为什么，为什么？你为什么不采取行动？
My father recalls that at this time, he felt his options went like this. He could leave his wife, and us with her, and seek a divorce. Or he could move in with us, get a job in the area, and look after his family the way he had promised in his wedding vows. So Dad announced that he intended to find a job in the area and move in with us as soon as possible. Mom flung her arms around his neck as if she were welcoming home a soldier.
父亲回忆起当时他觉得自己的选择是这样的。他可以离开他的妻子，带上我们，寻求离婚。或者他可以搬来和我们一起住，在当地找份工作，按照他在婚礼誓言中所承诺的那样照顾他的家庭。所以爸爸宣布他打算在当地找份工作并尽快搬来和我们同住。妈搂住他的脖子，就好像她在迎接回家的一名士兵。
That fall, the rains begin. The cottage has no gutters, and soon a drip line encircles our house like a moat. Each tide is higher than the last. I walked out at high tide and I am amazed to see the cove has spilled out of its banks and halfway toward the cottage. Minnows flick about the base of the holly tree and azalea bushes.
那年秋天，雨季开始了。小屋没有排水沟，很快一道滴水线像护城河一样环绕着我们的房子。每一波潮水都比前一波高。涨潮时我走出去，惊奇地看到海湾已经溢出了河岸，向小屋蔓延了一半。小鱼在冬青树和杜鹃花丛的根部跳动。
When I return to the cottage, Mom is putting things up on blocks in anticipation of the flood. We turn the kitchen chairs upside down on the table like we do every Friday afternoon at school. Mom gets some bricks from the woodshed, and we hoist up the sofa several inches off the floor. In times of real crisis, Mom loves to rally to the occasion. Now that it's going to flood, Emma gets a bedtime story, and is changed into a sweet terrycloth gown with a cartoon duck sewn on each pocket. Mom sits on the edge of my bed and brushes my hair the way she did when I was very young, and my whole body tingles.
当我回到小屋时，妈妈为了防洪把东西都架在砖块上。我们像每周五下午在学校一样把厨房椅子倒扣在桌子上。妈妈从木柴棚拿了一些砖头，我们把沙发抬离地面几英寸。在真正的危机时刻，妈喜欢动员大家应对。现在要发大水了，艾玛得到了睡前故事，换上了一件甜美的毛圈布睡袍，每个口袋上都绣着一只卡通鸭子。妈妈坐在我的床边，像我年幼时那样为我梳理头发，我的全身都酥麻了。
Mom goes into the supply box, and out comes a box of candles and rose matches. Soon the cottage is aglow inside. This place is meant for just this sort of warmth and quiet. The soft light seems to calm all of us. We eat our hot dogs together at the kitchen table in silence, while the world around us gets small and snug as we wait for disaster to strike.
妈妈走进补给箱，拿出一盒蜡烛和玫瑰火柴。很快小屋里便灯火通明。这个地方注定就是为了这种温暖和宁静。柔和的光线似乎让我们所有人都平静了下来。我们静静地坐在厨房桌子旁一起吃热狗，周围的世界在我们等待灾难降临时变得狭小而舒适。
Catherine Keener, reading an excerpt from Virginia Holman's memoir, Rescuing Patty Hearst . Once Virginia's dad finally convinced her mom to see a doctor, they learned that she'd been psychotic for five years.
凯瑟琳·基纳为您朗读弗吉尼亚·霍尔曼的回忆录《拯救帕蒂·赫斯特》的节选。一旦弗吉尼亚的父亲最终说服她母亲去看医生，他们才知道她已经精神病发作五年了。
Our program produced today by Lisa Pollak and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Kevin Clark.
我们的节目由丽莎·波拉克和我今天制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、温迪·多尔、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·凯尼格参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责运营我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和凯文·克拉克提供了制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS] You know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife. They have public radio programs, best-selling books, even the New York Times , all at audible.com. This American Life is treated by Public Radio International.
（致谢）你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频。他们有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资金赞助名单）
WBEZ management oversight by Mr. Torey Malatia, who reminds you:
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他提醒你：
Muslims rule, damn it.
穆斯林万岁，该死。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。